and we will get started. Hello, it's the 19th of June 2019. We have some questions at our Zoom
call that we want to go over first and then we will open it up for questions. Everybody is
muted right now. So if you do have a question about what I'm talking about, you can raise your
little hand on your thing and you can type in a question there. First question was about medical
immunotherapy that is the new drug that is a non chemo type drug for cancer that people have
questions about. So how does it work? Is it really immunotherapy because you think of
immunotherapy while you're thinking you're stimulating your immune system to help kill the cancer?
So we have to try to take a step back and understand a little bit of physiology and why my immune system
is effectively killing my cancer in the first place. So one of the struggles that our immune
system has in killing our cancer is that cancer is our own self tissue. So normally T cells,
macrophages, your immune white blood cells are not supposed to attack self tissue.
Otherwise it'd be called an autoimmune disease. So you have, in your cells, you have this receptor
and it's shown in this picture here. I think it's too technical but it's your PDL-1 receptor
that actually attaches to your PD-1 receptor on a T cell that tells the T cell, tells your
immune cells that hey, this is self tissue, don't kill me. This is throughout your whole body.
Two or cells are not the only cells that have this PD-1 receptor on it. All your human cells have
this receptor in order to tell the immune system not to kill it. Now what is supposed to happen with
a growing cancer is that the immune system should override this and kill this growing cancer because it's
it should sense it as being abnormal. This cell, this cancer is growing and replicating and replicating
and replicating, it should sense it as abnormal and it should kill it. But part of the problem in our
immune system's inability to do that is this PD-1 receptor. What the immutile therapy drugs like
Ketruda do is they are an eddy PD-1 analogue that attaches to that receptor on both the PDL-1
or the PD-1 and there are some other receptors that can get much more technical because there's
other drugs that are very similar to Ketruda that are tacky different receptors because there's
several different receptors in this in this family of receptors and what they what these drugs are
doing is binding to that receptor so my T cells will now attack the tumor cell. Well that sounds like
a wonderful thing, right? The problem is is that this issue here is not the whole story and it's not
the whole problem with with most cancers. That's why Ketruda in the immutile therapies are only approved
for certain cancers and then on other cancers they're only approved after chemotherapy is failed
and some people have said well that doesn't seem right my sister used Ketruda and it actually worked
and they won't give me Ketruda they said I have to do chemotherapy first. Well the reason is is that
your type of cancer this isn't really the problem so they only approve Ketruda for your type of
cancer when chemotherapy fails they have nothing else in the tool bag. That's how this works. Now the
problem with this you think wow this is this is miracle drug and it is wonderful so this is where my
inter grade of training is like wow this is fantastic this is a really cool drug set for really
stubborn cancers if they express the problem and there's a way to do the testing the genetic testing
if it's really a PDL1 problem in the first place now it's not exact science but it's the best that
we have right now then Ketruda may be very effective now there's huge side effects with it because
it's not going to be specifically binding this anti PD1 to just the PDL1 receptors on tumor
sites it does it throughout the whole body so you take Ketruda and your administered immutile therapy
drug it does this to all your cells so one of the things you'll be told is that one of the side
effects of an immunotherapy drug for cancer is that you could slash probably will get diseases that
end with anitis colitis is your number one thing that a person will get most people on Ketruda
they're going to get colitis because your immune system is now your T cells are going to start
attacking all your cells all your your normal self cells so the first thing that because your immune
system is so strong in the gut it's going to start attacking your gut wall cells so you end up with
colitis so very common side effect of Ketruda is bloody stools horrible diarrhea
and people could get this to whatever degree so that is that is an issue that you have to deal with
we've had people have lung issues we've had people their thyroid just goes crazy and they end up with
Hashimoto's or a Graves disease where people lose their hearing we've had people
list goes on and on any you're basically dealing with multiple autoimmune diseases
that's the risk in taking these drugs no no no to temper that down we've had people take these drugs
with very little side effects so everybody's going to react differently to these
so i don't want to knock them i think they're fantastic it's a great class of drugs that
it's going to be really neat if it can be specifically attacked the tumor cells
that hasn't been figured out yet that is a hopeful thing in the cancer realm
for those watching these drugs it could be a really big help who we're hoping that that does that
but that's the medical immunotherapy drugs that are out there again it's only has only been shown to really
be really effective with certain types of cancer and then even with that certain type of cancer
you're half your body has to express this pdl1 issue in the testing in order for it to really be
classified as a as a drug of choice for that person next question was about enzyme therapy we've
got multiple questions about enzyme therapy what is enzyme therapy i have multiple videos on our
website on enzyme therapy and on the blog post and in our youtube video library on enzyme therapy
and what we have done it stems from dr kelly's work who really put it on the
planet as far as a as a cancer therapy actually he got the information from dr john barbs work back
at the early 1900s and but dr kelly used it for himself for his own cancer he used it for multiple
patients that he helped work with with cancer and then later a student of his dr dickless guzzolus of
New York who is now passed away who i actually trained under he was a wonderful guy by the way super
great guy and he uses he used dr kelly's protocol basically with with pancreatic enzymes
so enzyme therapy with cancer is taking high doses of pancreatic enzymes to help digest the
slime layer that is a waste layer that builds up around a growing cancer because of the metabolic
activity that's taking place in rapid replication in this cancer and helps break that down and gives
your immune system the ability to kill it so we said back here that one of the reasons why our
immune system isn't effectively killing cancer is that the cancer cell is turning off the immune
system's ability to kill the cancer but there's other reasons the reason why these drugs the well
if that was the only reason that these drugs are a miracle drug and they're going to be curative
cancer the problem is that's not the only reason why the immune system isn't killing the cancer so
another major reason is because you a growing cancer mass is going to have it's going to build up
protein shell around it a waste such shell around it and that's where high dose
enzymes can be beneficial now this is different than taking digestive enzymes for helping you digest
your food maybe everybody should do that you could argue that but taking digestive enzymes to
help break down your food you take with your food all right before your meal right after your meal
you're getting the enzymes in there to help break up proteins so that you better digest and you
could better absorb take some pressure off your paincreas and take some pressure off your intestinal
tract you're going to have a greater absorption rate a lot of got issues are because of poor digestion
remember digestion is the breakdown of macro nutrients into smaller nutrients that we can absorb
and we have malabsorption problems because we don't do that very well especially we have decreased
stomach acid production and so much stress on our paincreas that we have decreased enzyme production
and just the bad diet of the foods that we're eating enzyme therapy for cancers taking very very
high doses in comparison so let's say if I'm going to take one enzyme pill before in my largest
meals with with with cancer enzyme therapy what type of enzymes you're using you're using anywhere
between 15 capsules twice a day to 75 capsules twice a day on an empty stomach now part of the problem
with Dr. Kelly's approach was compliance taking that many pills on an empty stomach became problematic
with some people now we have discovered using fermented enzymes in an improved formulation we've been
able to use the same protocol with a much lower dose this is the same as Dr. Kelly's enzyme formulation
that he used with this paincreatic 8 plus you have to use a much higher dose so if somebody was doing
Dr. Kelly's protocol they might be taking 35 to 75 of these twice a day we typically tell them
the morning right when they wake up told eat for an hour to two wait an hour to to eat before bed
take these right before bed with the digestimes we have people taking anywhere between 5 10 15 20
in the morning in the same of the afternoon in it varies pundose and we test people on that but this
you can take a much lower dose they're both about the same size capsule this makes it more doable
to do should every cancer patient be doing this enzyme therapy by belief no so just like should every
cancer patient be doing chemotherapy by belief no should we be doing a bit of therapy no should we
be doing protocell no you want to be as specific as possible and come up with a protocol that's
going to work for that patient but this is something that is just another cancer therapy and I've
answered questions on that that I want people to know what it is we have videos on this but don't
but don't take just because I'm doing some information on this that everybody should be doing this
so that's enzyme therapy helping break down the cancer by using paincreatic enzymes to help
break down that shell around the cancer cerebellum system can get at it and kill it all right so now
I'm going to open it up I'm going to unmute everybody and open it up for questions
we'll just I have about 10 15 minutes here we can get some questions in
questions here okay so keep asking everybody's asking really good questions on the Facebook page
and everybody's chiming in with answers and that's what it's really about we want you guys to be
participants helping one another supporting one another loving one another encouraging one another
on that page you know everybody has not you know a ton of knowledge and if you could help people with
your experience and your knowledge it's just such a blessing so encourage you to continue to do that
that's why we put that page together in the first place so we just love to see that it's starting
to really flow okay thanks so much for participating and make sure again a reminder if you have specific
questions that you want to dig into some answers with anything that you email the questions to the
cutters clinic at G-Bill or the info and cutters clinic but please put in the subject title
zoom question because we literally get at least 200 emails a day so put in there and I'll make sure
I catch it and you'll find it all right you guys have a wonderful day know that praying for you all
all the time at this light but the next one take a right I will see you guys next week